hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in essay one of the genealogy of morals
friedrich nietzsche
spends three chapters discussing
the development of this figure
and a mode of valuation that he calls
the priest and
this could be single individuals this
can be
an entire people as he says the the jews
are
it can be a cast so it can be something
in between
a sort of class emerging within the
aristocracy
and it's very important to take into
account
the fact that the priest is a third
figure
and a third form of valuation different
and distinct from
the aristocratic noble you know the
strong
mode of valuation of good versus bad
and the later development of herd
morality and the trans valuation of
values that culminates in good
versus evil the priest plays a role in
that
but there's also something different
going on so it's very important not just
to
turn everything into binaries as people
are
often want to do with nature and
recognize the complexity of the picture
that he's drawing
so the priest is a type
who emerges from the noble class they
don't emerge
from the underclass the commoners who
are being
oppressed and told that they're bad you
know by the
the nobles instead the priest is
something
new that's emerging within this
aristocracy
and he talks about the issue of
superiority
of soul and he says to this rule that
he's set up before
that a concept denoting political
superiority
always resolves itself into a concept
denoting superiority of soul
it is not necessarily an exception when
the highest
caste is at the same time the priestly
cast and therefore emphasizes in its
total description of itself
a predicate that calls to mind its
priestly function we'll talk about that
predicate in a moment predicate being a
judgment a value term in this case
so it could be that it is the highest
caste within the society and we might
think about
for example the development in india
where the brahmanas
are higher than the kishitria who are
the warriors and rulers and
and stuff like that but the key thing
here is that there is a differentiation
within the aristocracy a little bit
later in in chapter seven he tells you
the priestly mode branches off from the
nightly aristocratic
and then can develop into its opposite
and he says this is particularly
likely when the priestly cast and the
warrior cast
are in jealous opposition to one another
and are unwilling to
come to terms there's a conflict not
only
of peoples but of you might say ways of
looking at the world
and at oneself and what one's doing so
there's a lot of different ways in which
this can develop you can have
a priestly cast that's over the
aristocratic class
right you can have a priestly class sort
of going to battle
but not you know using the weapons of
war but other weapons
with this noble class there's a lot of
different possibilities
and one society could actually contain
multiple
cases of that so what is this priestly
mode
of valuation nietzsche tells us
that this priestly mode brings in some
new values he says
pure and impure confront one another for
the first time
as designations of station and here here
too there evolves a good and a bad
in a sense no longer referring to
station so something is getting shaken
loose something is
happening this is part of you know human
you could call it
productivity with ideas the fact that we
are an animal
that is not entirely determined or
conditioned
in the ways that other animals are this
is part of human development according
to nietzsche
so this pure versus impure as a new way
of looking at
good versus bad a person could be
from the higher class but still be
impure
and therefore bad in this priestly mode
of of valuation so
he goes on and he says at first we
should be warned against taking these
too broadly
or symbolically all the concepts of
ancient people
were at first incredibly uncouth course
external he goes on
and altogether unsymbolical so what's
the opposite of
symbolic literal right literally pure
the pure one
he says is from the beginning merely a
man who washes himself
who forbids himself certain foods that
produce skin ailments
who does not sleep with the dirty women
of the lower strata who has an aversion
to blood
no more hardly more now you know is
nietzsche getting this from some
history that he's discovered no this is
his his introjection of it but
it's a plausible story right so he says
on the other hand
it's clear from the whole nature of an
essentially priestly
aristocracy why antithetical evaluations
could soon become dangerously deepened
sharpened and internalized so
at first the distinction is very
straightforward you know do these things
don't do these things
don't get leprosy for example you know
uh if you've got this sort of
skin ailment which which could be
leprosy or something else stay away from
everybody else
we have to purify you in certain ways
don't have sex
except under these circumstances
but then the distinction can be
elaborated it can be developed
and here's where the priestly cast or
figure
becomes something very interesting and
new
on the scene he tells us there is from
the first something unhealthy
in these priestly aristocracies and in
the habits ruling them
which turn them away from action and
alternate between brooding and emotional
explosions
habits which seem to have as their
almost invariable consequence that
intestinal morbidity right
something wrong with your guts quite
quite frankly and neuroestemia
uh you know sort of not perceiving
things
which afflicted priests at all times but
and then here's where it gets more
complex
as to it's that which they themselves
devised as a remedy
must one not assert that it has
ultimately proved itself a hundred times
more dangerous in its effects
than the sickness it was supposed to
cure so the priests
act as you could say physicians
physicians not only the body but the
soul
and they develop more and more cures
which then provoke
other problems and people can come to
them
for you know help but oftentimes they
leave with just as many
new problems as they came in with and he
says
mankind is still ill with the effects of
this priestly naivete and medicine
think for example of certain forms of
diet of fasting of sexual continence
of flight into the wilderness and he
brings up a popular cure
at the time which was actually an
american guy
preaching that and he says add to these
the entire
anti-sensualistic metaphysics of the
priest
that makes people indolent and over
refined their
auto hypnosis right there and then
finally the
only two comprehensible satiety with
this
together with the radical cure for it
nothingness
or god the desire for union mystical
with god is the desire of the buddhist
for nothingness
nirvana no more and then he says with
the priests
because of this everything becomes more
dangerous
the priest is now the warriors are
dangerous right i mean they might kill
you they might enslave you
but they're dangerous in a very
different way
than the priest is the priest is
dangerous to
himself to to other people and can
work on a different plane than that of
the
warriors right he goes on and he says
for these priests everything becomes
more dangerous you have dangers you have
to avoid so you can remain
pure cures and remedies but also
arrogance revenge acuteness prolificacy
love lust to rule virtue disease
and then he says something quite
interesting here that i think is
very important to take into account is
nietzsche condemning the priests
no nietzsche is saying this is something
that happened
and this actually led to human beings
becoming the interesting animal before
that i mean they were doing stuff that
we write you know stories about
conquering places people would come in
and assert themselves with the powerful
jockey with each other
for prestige and position get into blood
feuds with each other
oppress the common people but it's just
the same damn thing over and over and
over again
one place another place another place
it's the priests
and the religion that they bring which
makes human beings more complex which
makes them
more interesting not only from a
anthropological point of view
but from a moral point of view
as well so he calls this the soil of an
essentially
dangerous form of human existence the
priestly form and it's
only there that man became an
interesting animal
only here did the human soul in a higher
sense
acquire depth acquire depth but also
become evil and these are the two basic
respects in which man has hitherto been
superior
to other beasts being able to comprehend
oneself not only as just
bad and not fitting well into the social
hierarchy of being weak as opposed to
the strong
but evil and being able to diagnose evil
in others
right so that is part of what makes us
the interesting animal
in uh chapter seven and chapter eight he
talks about
impotence and he says that the priest
is the most evil enemy why because they
are the most impotent it's because of
their impotence
that in them hatred grows to monstrous
and uncanny
proportions to the most spiritual and
poisonous kind of hatred they
can't win on the same plane as the
warriors
right so they find a new game they re
they change the rules
they bring in new concepts where they
can be
the winners that's kind of a sour grapes
thing
but it's not just sour grapes it's
developing an entirely
new set of approaches to things that are
motivated
also by a hatred that can last and last
and last
that can deepen that can turn into
different permutations
they're aiming at what nietzsche calls
spiritual revenge
and they are motivated by a kind of what
he calls resentment and i should point
out
that nietzsche thinks that rizontamont
is not just something for the lower
classes
not just something for the priest people
can feel risantomonth
the nobles feel it but then they let it
go whereas the priest
holds on to it and sharpens it so
he tells us that human history once
again going back to the
interesting animal would all be
altogether too stupid a thing
without the spirit that the impotent
have introduced to it
and here he gets into a long discussion
spanning this chapter and bleeding over
into
chapter eight about the jews and it's
you know it's hard to figure
out exactly what we ought to make of
this because if you do know anything
just reading the bible for example
it's clear that you know the jews were
not one single
people always on the same page ruled by
the priests or anything like that
there's actually a lot of jockeying
between the priests and the kings
and various prophets and you know
problems within the priesthood and you
know
foreign relations with other nations and
but you you can say that
um within you know judaism there are
some
important traits that that are being
developed that
help you see what nietzsche is trying to
get at here i
i suspect that if nietzsche were looking
at chinese history and had enough
background in it he probably would have
talked about the confusions
in a similar way himself now be that as
it may he says that
here all that has been done against uh
on earth against the noble the powerful
the masters the rulers
fades into nothing compared with what
the jews have done against them
that priestly people who in opposing
their enemies and conquerors
were ultimately satisfied with nothing
less than a radical
reevaluation of their enemy's value that
is to say an act of the most spiritual
revenge and again it's if you think
about the biblical literature it's a
little hard to
see exactly what nietzsche is aiming at
because
there is this like saying ah you know
the the moabites they're a bunch of bad
people
um you know and the assyrians come in
and sort of the
babylonians and the egyptians they're
all bad people too
but israel's doing its israel and judea
are doing their own similar things and
conquering other
places and cyrus the great is
acclaimed as you know the anointed of
god so i you got to take this with a
little bit of a
a grain of salt here and try to see what
he's trying to talk about
now he he then goes and and brings up
christianity
and before that though he says that
um there is this in a inversion of the
aristocratic value equation
hanging on to this inversion with their
teeth the teeth of the most divisible
hatred
saying the wretched alone or the good
the poor impotent lowly alone or the
good the suffering deprived sick
ugly alone or pious alone are blessed by
god
blessedness is for them alone and it's
it's difficult to again to identify
this in historical forms of judaism but
you know you could say well this is kind
of a type that he's after
the real meat i would say in this is in
uh chapter eight where he switches to
talking about christianity which
you know certainly for europe and really
across the world
has a influence in spreading a
priestly mode of evaluation according to
nietzsche's standards
that dwarfs that of judaism right
because christianity effectively takes
over the west
right so he he says that um
what about christianity it's usually
portrayed
as the opposite of judaism as
love in place of hatred and he says no
no this jesus of nazareth
this incarnate gospel of love the
redeemer brought blessedness and victory
to the poor
was he not the seduction in its most
uncanny
and irresistible form a seduction and
bypass to these jewish values and new
ideas
did not israel attain the ultimate goal
of its supreme sublime vengefulness
through
through the bypass of this redeemer this
ostensible opponent and disintegrator
of israel isn't isn't this really just
another
kind of priestly
reevaluation of things
much more successful much more seductive
more complex
that's nietzsche's point in turning to
this historical thing
the other thing that we do have to point
out is that the priests play
an important role in what he's going to
call the slave revolt in morality
but they are not just like imposing it
on the common people as a matter of fact
there's kind of a dialectic going on
between them right and again
historically
since nietzsche says we really need to
attend to history
it's not really that simple is that the
priests are often
getting into a lot of conflict with the
common people
over these sorts of things so we really
do have to see it as
a third kind of valuation within this
complex dynamic that nietzsche is laying
out
but this is this is very important the
priests
later on in the essay uh in
in the third essay right
are going to be connected with the
philosophers and even
the people of science the questors for
truth and the ascetic ideal
this is where that's first coming in to
the work and establishing as we said
something something new nietzsche
doesn't
take a stance on whether this is really
fundamentally good or bad
he's saying here's what i think happened
and here's how these developments play
out
you